au cœur des préoccupations un
partenariat a été signé entre RDF
l'école de la deuxième chance de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines est bleu
oxygène développement avec le soutien de
Benoît Hamon ministre de l'économie
sociale et solidaire c'est très
important qu'on est comme ça des grandes
entreprises qui s'engagent parce que
sans l'engagement de ces grandes
entreprises ça fait autant de chantier
en moins et d'autant d'opportunités de
réinsérer des gens qui qui nous
échapperaient et c'est pour ça que cet
engagement volontaire d'une entreprise
comme RDF ça mérite d'être salué au
total une centaine de jeunes adultes aux
faibles niveau scolaires et concernés
par ce dispositif alors que le chômage
est toujours en progression dans le
département au mois de mars près de 60
000 demandeurs d'emploi a été
comptabilisés c'est 970 demandeurs
d'emploi supplémentaires par rapport au
mois de février
le plus important c'est qu'on commence à
pouvoir envoyer que des stagiaires
soient accueillis à au sein de
l'entreprise ERDF qui puisse découvrir
leur métier et puis éventuellement si la
rencontre se fait il y en a probablement
quelques-uns d'entre eux qui ont envie
d'embaucher et ça c'est le cœur de notre
métier s'il y a des profils qui nous
intéressent à l'issue de ces formations
et des personnes qui souhaitent
intégrer notre entreprise nous sommes
favorables à examiner leurs dossiers à
peu près un quart de nos embauches qui
proviennent à l'apprentissage à peu près
30 personnes sur l'ouest francilien et
puis et puis éventuellement les
embaucher même en direct des mauvais
chiffres du chômage à contrasté avec ces
deux annonces économiques vendredi la
direction de Renault a annoncé que
l'usine de Flins allait fabriquer la
prochaine génération de Nissan Micra à
partir de 2016 avec pour objectif de
produire 82000 véhicules d'ici 2017 de
son côté le département des Yvelines
s'engagent à financer sans emploi
d'avenir exclusivement pour les jeunes
issus des foyers bénéficiaires du RSA
situé dans les zones de redynamisation
urbaine comme Mantes-la-Jolie Poissy ou
trappes ils viennent s'ajouter à
l'objectif de 950 contrats et des soit
au total plus de 1000 contrats